[Musique]
non
et où
simone
[Musique]
êtes vous si vous regardez les ennemis
qu'il y un spectacle bien s'adapter ami
qu'est ce que c'est ils ont cassé mais
qu'est ce qui t'arrive point qu on
devine pas bah non non je vois pas
tentant alors commencera que manches à
une
tu essaies de te gratter le dos un comme
ça à la non non non pas du tout c'est
pas ça non alors continue continue
ah oui mais tu cherche à écraser un
moustique qui t'a piqué là ça parce que
tu n'as rien compris
regarde moi bien grave si je crois que
tu répètes amine pour la fête de l'école
c'est ça mais non ce n'est pas ça du
tout je me prépare à mon futur métier
un futur métier tu veux dire de cassis
mûre que tu veux travailler
ouais et alors ben bassat sait très bien
que c'est bien bravo bravo et mais dis
donc qu'est ce que tu veux faire non pas
tu n'as pas lu le journal de l'île aux
enfants ce matin et si ces biens seront
alors qu'il n'a pas vus par un titre en
première page
à tort ayew je me souviens il y avait un
gros titres là il y avait marqué qu'on
demandait des candidats pour être le
premier astronaute de l'île aux enfants
aller sur la lune
ouais et didon au tour de me dire que tu
veux aller sur la lune comme astronaute
buzz et 1026 et alors
m'enfin casimir t/t beaucoup trop gros
et puis tu sais il faut être très très
très très savants quoi très intelligent
je suis gros même pu me dis ça parce que
tu es jaloux
nous allons mener au gpl quand j'aurai
fini mon entraînement je saurai de
meilleur astronautes du monde tu sais
casino parmi nous il ya peut-être aussi
d'autres candidats et puis si j'ai une
petite idée que le jour où la fusée
décollera de l'île aux enfants avec des
astronautes à bord eh ben c'est pas pour
demain et tous autant qu'on y est on a
le temps de grandir
tu crois mais c'est très bien on va
pouvoir s'entraîner tous ensemble c'est
ça c'est ça notre stop ça casimir les
enfants les alexandre eric est vite vite
par la la mettez-vous par là où on va
s'entraîner pour être à la hauteur
est-ce que parmi vous il y en a qui
aimeraient astronautes astronautes pour
aller dans la lune
nathalie la jemmerais
oui voilà les la concurrence à tous tous
ouvriers allaient dans la lune
oh là là alors je vous pose une question
et à vous aussi chez vous un jour poser
une question est ce que vous savez quand
pour la première fois l'homme a posé le
pied sur la lune
vous savez ouais ya pas très longtemps
il ya combien de temps n'y a pas
longtemps c'est vrai que j'aime et je
donne la réponse
eh bien il ya cinq ans cinq ans c'était
le 16 juillet 1969
ah ouais au cours du vol apollo 11
et comment s'appelait l'astronaute celui
qui dirigeait l'expédition nicolas tran
son prénom
neil amstrong et comment s'appelait ses
deux coéquipiers eux
et bien il y avait aldrin et collins ans
les trois étaient américains serait
quasiment furent comme il ya quelque
chose de beaucoup plus mystérieux encore
si la face cachée de la lune c'est quand
on est sur terre on voit toujours la
même face de la lune vous le saviez mais
en novembre 1959
les russes ont envoyé un satellite qui
s'appelle unique 3 est l'unique 3 a pris
une photographie de la face cachée de la
lune
voilà j'ai bien compris c'est sûr elles
ont fait une démonstration un pouce et
vous laisser toute la place
on pousse beaucoup de places d'honneur
ont vachement aux astronautes
tu sais ce qu'on fait qu'ils aient mis
non moi je suis le soleil un foyer cela
permet rayon lac ibrir devrait chauffer
la 1 et casimir toi tu vas faire la
terre le père alors comment la terre
tourne-t-elle autour du soleil
comment alors tourner des jeux tu
expliques tu tournes thorough tourne
autour de moi voilà c'est ça et en même
temps tout prendre sur toi même à la la
la rotation massaguet de la terre je
suis la terre autour du soleil
je suis la paire vous ai compris je suis
là
mais toi la bouche à bouche pas
admettons que moi j'habite ici sur la
terre au bout du nez de casimir 1 donc
quand le soleil est en face c'est le
jour
maintenant quasi me retourne fait à
rotation vous suivez un nouveau site
stop casino casini alors moi j'habitais
au bout du nez de casimir voyez
maintenant c'est la nuit pour moi et
c'est par ici
le jour où j'ai compris alors mon nez
savoir mine d'or casimir aisée mon ami
mon essai le juillet la voilà voilà
c'est la nuit prononcée le jour quoi je
suis dans l'app store
entre autres choses casimir ouais on
fait autre chose tu vas faire la lune
la rotation de la lune autour de la
terre alors regardez observez bien
regardez bien parler ou si c'est très
différent parce que la lune autour de la
terre tourne tout autour de la terre
mais sans tourner sur elle-même fait la
rotation comme ça or voilà là je suis la
terre je suis la lune juste l'algérie
je suis la lune la lune au change si
cela était à la terre à terre je suis la
ferté allais les affaires allaient bien
alors toi aussi j'ai dû traîner avec moi
comme ça tu pourras satellite ka-sat il
appert allez allez regarder le spi la
terre c'est la terre je suis la tâche
allait voir la lune la lune
telle est la nuit là lui et la gym pas
sur vilaine
c'est là que se situe la terre je savais
que tu étais je suis allée la lune la
lune la lune pas l'une je suis très
terre à terre par hectare de terre la
terre la terre les terres tu la lutte
marine alors gelé
je la lui tenait les tue la terre à
terre tu es tu as des patères la tête
quand je suis là fait la lutte va faire
vraiment je ne savais pas qu'il y avait
autant de satellites artificiels dans
l'espace